hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast integrative cancer immunology
and novel concepts of cancer evolution
presented by dr. jerome guilin research
director french institute of health and
medical research
i am xavier tears of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin i would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speakers will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Callum I will
turn the presentation over to him thank
you hello everybody so I'm gonna discuss
today novel concept of cancer evolution
and the importance of immunology in
cancer so here are my disclosures on the
co-founder of and oncology diagnostic
company and I do talk to people in
industry so as you all know the
definition of cancer is based and the
severity of cancer is based on a
traditional staging system basically
showing that the cancer is progressing
into a primary organ and that is the T
stage and additional parameters like the
invasion
no distant metastases are essential key
elements to classify cancer patients
into early stage disease or late stage
disease we all know cancer is a genetic
disease due to mutation to alteration of
the genome to chromosomal instability
microsatellite instability sera and his
tumor aggressiveness parameter
progression of a cancer invasion defines
early and late stage cancer and of
course patients are treated accordingly
to their stage what I'd like to discuss
today is a totally different concept on
a novel prime for cancer where in fact
we propose that there is a dynamic
interaction between tumor cells and
immune cells and in fact what we showed
was that all these key criteria of tumor
progression the invasion of a cancer the
metastasis the records of a cancer are
all dependent on the pre-existing
immunity and on immuno score that is the
measure of T cells inside a tumor
in fact the fate of the tumor cells is
dependent on the pre-existing immunity
and on T cells for existing immunity of
the patient is determining the fate and
the survival of the patient and now that
we have efficient immunotherapies what
we see is that this pre-existing
immunity and T cell response is also
determining the likelihood of response
to immunotherapy so will not focus at
least at the beginning on a particular
molecule on a particular pathway I don't
have any favorite cells but really what
we wanted to do was to decipher and to
analyze deeply in a comprehensive manner
the tumor micro-environment
in large parts of human patients to try
with systems biology to understand what
is the tumor micro-environment and how
this is important so here is an example
of a tumor a cancer colorectal cancer
you can see
the tumor cells on top the normal
epithelial surrounding this tumor you
can see massive - random fluid
structures and inside the tumor and
surrounding the tumor and invasive model
of the treatment you can find basically
every single subset of immune cells all
subsets of T cells T helper cells th1
th2 th17 regulatory t-cells all subsets
of memory T cells of b-cells all the
subsets of innate cells they are all
present no cancers are different density
is different level different locations
different activation status but they are
all there so the first thing we asked
was really what is the importance of
this pre-existing immunity in human
tumors
does it really matter and what we found
back in 2005 in this article that we
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine was that indeed they are
important in univer amateurs that are
associated with the presence or absence
of early metastatic invasion science
that is the presence of tumor cells
inside the blood vessels or the
lymphatic vessels and in fact what we
found was that there is a good immunity
in particular memory T cells and in
particular effector memory T cells but
correlated with the absence of this
early metastatic invasion preventing
those and correlating with an improved
clinical outcome in the patients here is
an example of some of the studies we did
we did lash facts phenotyping looking at
fresh tumors on the left side of the
slide you can see in each column here
represent one tumor from one patient and
you can see more than 400 subpopulations
of immune cells analyzed by flow
cytometry from those flesh tumors and
when we look at the patient's having or
not having these early metastatic
signs we could see that they are indeed
some T cells a popular
Asians that are significantly different
between the positive ability
publications and ability negative
actions in particular markers of t-cell
activation is cell differentiation the
th1 subsets and the memory t-cells so we
went deeper into the analysis of these
memory T cells and cytotoxic T cells and
really quantify them in a deep manner
and these letters to publish this paper
in science which was the foundation for
this new concept of immune contexture
and I will describe and for this assay
immuno school so what we did at the time
was the quantification with digital
pathology of more than 6,000 immuno stew
chemistry quantifying the densities of
different subtypes of adaptive immune
cells within the tumors taking into
account not only the type of immune
cells not only the density but also
their locations
location in different areas of the tumor
so here is the survival curves of the
patients according to the international
AG CCU ICC TNM classification based on
tumor is topological findings this is
the current bolstered our classification
you can see on the x-axis here more than
15 years of follow-up and you can see
patients relaxing Stage one patients
having small tumors t1 t2 stage 2
patients having more advanced t3 t4
tumors patient with stage 3 having lymph
node metastasis now when we did the
quantification of the T cells and in
particular the memory T cells taking
into account where they are located in
the center near CT or in the invasive
margin here I am we quantify the
densities of memory T cells in the
embezzled model and the densities in the
center of Italy what we found was that
the patient with a high density of
memory keys as involved in region
an excellent outcome as you can see more
than 80% of the patients at no tumor
records or more than 16 years and this
was happening regardless of the stage of
the patients even a patient at a late
stage tumor what is considered today a
late stage tumor those patients were
protected and did not get human records
in the opposite the patients who had low
densities of memory t-cells in both
human region at a dramatic calm as you
can see regardless of their tumor stage
even patients in an early stage will
have a very rapid human recurrence which
means that the coordinated adaptive
immune reaction measuring the t-cells
inside the tumor more than the classic
of tumor invasion parameters really
predicts the clinical outcome of the
patient so this was showing for the
first time that the priest in a minute B
and T cells when put in the cox
multivariate analysis and this was shown
for the first time for any chance that
this evaluation of the immune cells
which is in fact the immuno score assay
is highly highly significant in a cox
multivariate analysis this multivariate
analysis is testing the strength of the
parameters and the dependency of the
parameters and not only aminos Cohen's
highly significant but for the first
time what we found was that the T stage
the instant the greater differentiation
of the cuber are no longer significant
they are all statistically dependent on
the immuno score on the t cell
pre-existing mean that the patients have
in their humans which brings a novel par
time for cancer because now this new
this classical classification of answer
is no longer significant so we decided
to put this into the concept of immune
contexture so the contexture is the act
of assembling part into a whole that are
the arrangements of interconnected parts
so these four important
amateurs in terms of the immune my
compartment
the nature of immune cells the type of
immune cells the immune functional
orientation of the response in
particular th1 cells the density of the
immune cells within the tumor and the
location of these immune cells in
particular at the invasive margin of the
tumor and in the trauma center and we
propose that these are essential
parameters which we analyze more deeply
into this paper that we published by in
the DCO in 2011 on this paper we
analyzed the reason why on a Cox
multivariate analysis when we put all
the key criteria is the key pathological
finding the T stage and stage a number
of names know the histological grade etc
all those parameters are no longer
significant and a statistically
dependent on the pre-existing we meet on
the crazies in T cells measured by you
know small only bowel perforation as you
can see remain significant which is
quite bad and immuno score and a direct
comparison of the a Jesus devices in TNM
classification with the immuno score
classification or DFS overall survival a
digit specific survival show the power
and the significance of numerous core
classification and the dependency of the
clinical situation and together with all
people we had this point provocative
editorial TNM staging T's for T cell and
M is for memory so back in 2006 when we
public is people we put patients in two
major categories of humors in terms of
immunity thracian the high immuno score
the optimal immune respond also called
inflamed tumors or hot tumors are the
ones having long-term survival the
absence the low immuno score patients
also called non inflamed of cold tumors
put them into this big two category we
also did
Chateauguay is with this altered immune
reaction is intermediate in venous Cole
having an intermediate immune response
which we also subdivided into two
mechanistic distinct alteration either
the exclusion phenotype which is due to
the accumulation of t-cells and invasive
mode only person we altered phenotype
that is due to convene a suppressive
mutant and this is actually the figure
of the paper that we published back in
2009 way before immuno therapy was so
popular showing that in fact the risk of
relapse at two years when the patients
have an optimal immune reaction on top
with a high immuno score of tumors these
patients have less than 10% risk of
reliability when they have an altered
immune response the risk of relax at two
years of the patient is 50% it can be
due to two distinct mechanisms either
this immunosuppressive phenotype or is
exclusion phenotype with a loss of
coordination and pistols only
surrounding the fingers not getting in
worse case scenario the patient's having
low in you know score no sign of t-cell
response these core tumors they have a
risk of relapse at two years at 80% and
we publish that back for the first time
this categorization of patient based on
Union parameters in 2009 we are now more
and more refining this immune contexture
so consisting in these four categories
the type of immune cells the density the
location and the functional immune
orientation basically measured measuring
the cells quantifying them taking into
account the spatial localization but
also measuring the quality of the immune
response with signatures we can see some
of the important million families here
we also did a study to evaluate whether
the evaluation
immune cells in particular cytotoxic T
cell density could also predict
early-stage risk and it is known for
colon cancer that patients with stage 2
stage 1 2 will have about 20% risk of
relapse which we can see on these
survival curves here this dotted line
shows that there is about 20% of the
patients who will experience a relaxed
even though they have a small tumor
state 1 2 and this is 18 years of
follow-up of course these patients is
20% of patients would be important to
know which one they are because there is
no recommendation for adjuvant treatment
these patients have their surgery and
most of them go home so evaluating the
mineral score that is the quantification
of the cytotoxic T cells in the center
and invasive mounting of the tumor
showed the following results patients
with an imino score for so high
densities of many cytotoxic T cells in
both regions by hi-hi-hi those patients
have an excellent outcome what a 95
percent of the patient will survive with
no recommend for 18 years they are safe
but the patients with middle score 1 2
or even worse the yellow curve immuno
score zero these patients are very high
rates of human recollects even though
they have an early stage tumor so it is
possible to see based on the T cell
evaluation and the T cell dense with
this measurement what are the high
wastage and again when we do the Cox
multivariate analysis what we can see is
that the T stage is dependent upon this
immune evaluation
so of course this could have very
important clinical implication and we
know now that we have immunotherapy is
that
immunotherapies are working and are not
working on old age and when you have
these two types of patient the cool
tumors immuno score zero with move
she sells these patients are very
unlikely respond checkpoint inhibitor
and he ctla-4 and TPD one that are
targeting the two cells these patients
with consumers they first need a t-cell
priming before to come with a checkpoint
blood
in contrast the patients with you know
score for humor is full of t-cells
pre-existing t-cells are the most likely
to respond 2020 PD country but biology
is not as simple as these two extreme
and in fact with immuno score evaluate
the immuno Square evaluation we can
measure all the subtypes and densities
of immune cells of immunity cells from
immuno score zero to universe all four
and we can also highlight the different
immune defects in different cultures so
we develop software one of which is
Kruger they will be published in pine
for Maddox it's the number one most
downloaded software on the UCSD a
website with more than 100,000 downloads
basically facilitating the biological
rotation of large data set and we also
created another software to pedia that
is also published in bioinformatics also
a lot of downloads basically adding your
experimental data the knowledge the
knowledge of multiple databases that are
publicly available in order to add data
and knowledge to your exponents so we
did that using our tools fluent camellia
and what we did was to add the question
what makes the difference between
patients having a hot tumor in low score
high versus cold tumors inglis posterior
and here is a list of genes that we
found to be significantly associated
with high and low immuno score and with
the survival of the patients but each
node represent one gene the color of the
gene with its function and the
connections a correlation between those
genes and to these data we added
conserved genomic Neverhood
data from publicly available databases
fado genetic profiling from public
databases co-expression analyses
chlorine-chlorine interaction receptor
ligand interaction functional genomics
database is like a symmetric state TCGA
data etc doing silly computation and we
end up showing that a network with some
mathematics prediction and you can see
from those prediction were two families
of molecules the chemokines including
sex ratio 160 and 96 and pencil i'm and
adhesion molecules and so with these
hypothesis now we went back to all
patients and eat the experimental
validation to see whether those
predictions and chemokines and adhesion
molecules were important and reported in
this paper but he does intend that
indeed these are essential molecules to
attract and to get increased density the
crystals inside the human so we are
alighting several mechanisms that are
associated with diesel infiltration the
attraction of subtypes of immune cells
with different subtypes of t-cells that
are attracted by different chemo clients
and in another paper published in
Science Translational Medicine in 2014
we are lighted a number mechanism
explaining the high densities of t-cells
through the local lymphocytic
proliferation that is mediated by the
level of expression of a cytokine I will
15 inside the tumor that is basically
expanding the pool of the activated t
cells basically giving to immune related
mechanisms that are associated with
diesel infiltration
hi minnows or an opportunity we also
went into the analysis of tumors to see
what is the spatial temporal dynamics of
the evolution of the u.s. ones with the
- mantra crashing because this is not a
static endpoint the tumors are
progressing from the inside - if you
want to keep it in parallel there is an
evolution of the immune response
different immune cell types are present
different activation level and
immunosuppressive mechanisms are in
place and we wanted to evaluate this
spatial sample dynamics and we end up
showing me in your landscape in human
tumors newspaper published immunity in
2013 in fact what we did for the first
time was to evaluate the immune ohm that
is the specific immune gene signatures
coming from purified immune cells
subpopulations so in each column here
you are different in cell types for
example on at the beginning here top
left corner B cells and T cells and in
subsets of Jesus and you can see for
example neutrophils mast cells
macrophages Sarah and you have here the
main the main genes are the most
specific genes that are upregulated only
in one specific in itself and we applied
this even on is something now that is
very popular to the human tumors to
basically evaluate the immune
composition of a tumor coming from a
complex mixture of cells by the
convolution of the complex expression
profiles this is very popular of course
this has advantages and disadvantages
and we've validated our findings by
doing the remaining quantification of
different of all those different immune
cell types by a ministry chemistry and
quantification by counting the number of
cell per square millimeter of tissue
plays in measuring the immune cell
density so here each peak
represent the height of the P represent
the cell density immune cell death you
can see a network with
letting the correlation and the same
behavior between the cells and you can
see two subnetwork the blue one that is
the quantification in the center of the
tumor personally yellow one that is the
quantification at the impassive margin
you can also see sub networks you and
you can see that the density is very
much dependent upon where you are want
to find those cells for example B cells
are found at very high densities on the
right side here
I mean passive margin and on the far
left you can see the B cell
quantified in the center of very low
that you can also see selves that are
outside of the network like the
granulocytes 17:3 using cells and having
similar behavior now instead of plotting
the density which is very informative we
looked at the evolution of those ten
seasons with the progression from t1 his
state to t2 t3 and t4 stage and could
show that indeed there are some immune
densities and in cells that are coming
into the tumors on that are decreasing
when the tumor is progress
and then we look at the impact of each
of those immune cells on the survival of
the patient instead of plotting the
other rate be the densities like here
now we are plotting in the same network
yes a ratio that is the impact on the
survival impact for each of those cells
the green Peaks represent the good
immune cells high-density is correlating
with prolonged survival and you can see
that this major network are all green
Peaks except the two little bad peaks of
cd68 macrophages but a slightly bad here
but all the subsets of T cells except
they are 1720 cells all the subsets of T
follicular out the cells and B cells are
associated with a prolonged survival and
we could show the difference between T 1
T 2 T 3 T
of those densities and show how each of
those cells were changing from one state
to the other basically showing that the
adaptive immune cells including the
distance cd8 cd3 c7 activated cells
memory clean cell cytotoxic T cells Fox
p3 gives us we're decreasing with the
progression of the tumor in contrast
there was an early increasing densities
of many innate cells and T follicular
alpha cell and a late increase in the B
cells the cells in himself that were
associated with tumor recurrence of the
T cell subsets including the pitch
wander cytotoxic and a memory T cells
the T follicular L discuss on the
default all being with info and so we
put this idea that they are important
immune parameters coming from and
especially infrastructures running
humors acting through the T follicular
out the cells that are producing the
cytokine out 21 and the chemokines extr
13 that are important to shape the
proper immune contexture inside the
tumor in particular the generation of
the good site of accident which one
response so going deeper into the
analysis of the tumors human tumors we
were very interested by a subgroup of
patients that have a specific type of
genetic alteration these patients have a
DNA mismatch repair deficiency they also
called MSI patients for microsatellite
instability the characteristic of these
patients because of their DNA mismatch
repair deficiency is that they are
unable cannot repair mutations that are
appearing on genome in particular frame
shifted agents and frame shift petitions
are very interesting from animal called
polar view for two reasons one because
they are not random
the frameshift mutations happens on the
genome on repetitive sequence on the
genome like a suite of a very often
there is an additional a and when the
demon is such prepared the fission it
cannot be repaired and for animal oh
jeez this friendship is edition of the
new a shift the code and therefore the
chlorine becomes completely different
and this new protein generates new
peptides that are totally different from
self peptide and therefore many of these
are invention and can be detected by the
immune system so we analyzed the
mechanistic relationship between the
tumor genotype the microsatellite
instability status of the patients and
the immune response and in particular
Amira score we quantified two large
chords including one corner of more than
200 patients from the TCGA and record on
more than 600 patients from our hospital
we did multiple different types of
approach basically to analyze deeply the
mechanistic relationship between the
microsatellite instability status and
the patients and the generation of an
immune response what we found was that
looking at the genomics on top you
having bloated MSI patients and in white
the MSS patients looking at the
chromosomal instability here on top is
blue and red lines and then looking at
the mutation profiles of those tumors
and all the mutations main driver
mutation in that case here and looking
at the transcriptome of those tumors
looking at all the genes are
significantly different between MSI
patients and MSS tension in the tumors
we found that there are more than 400
genes that are increased in MSI tumors
and more than 400 genes are the
creatures when we look at the function
all those genes across the genome we
were surprised to see that
there were no major green functions
meaning down regulation of genes we are
not belonging to a particular function
but for the upregulated genes as you can
see from all those red nodes they belong
to consistent families of molecules that
as you can see are very relevant for the
immune system
although gene for many abilities the
majority of it were immune related genes
from the interferon gamma media insulin
pathway from the antigen processing and
presentation from peptide antigen
positive regulation of leukocyte
migration of immune cells response to
TNF etc so we looked whether those
mutations were appearing and indeed as
you can see from this long scale number
of SS friendship mutations you can see
that patients with MSI you have more
friendship in patient a patient with an
X X and as I told you these mutations
are not random and so we predicted the
top 20 regions on a genome having
repetitive sequence where there is a
very high likelihood of having a
friendship attention and we validated
these women in an essay here and as you
can see in blue now is the validation of
the friendship potential indeed we found
frameshift mutations here at the bottom
of hte one gene of path one BG tgf-beta
are two very frequently having
frenchification in contrast to MSS
agents not only the beauty of that is
that we could with this compare the
observed versus expected number of
friendship and missense mutations and
also the observe an expected number of
immuno genic mutations by doing exotic
seeing RNA sequencing the detection
mutation the violent calling finding the
HLA a prototype of the patient doing
epitope binding prediction hlad star
binding prediction giving basically
immunogenicity score for each of the
mutation and we could compare the silent
mutation those that are not changing the
amino acid and are irrelevant for the
immune system versus the non-immigrant a
computation versus the one with a high
immunogenicity score is immunogenic
mutations and so we compare the rate of
mutations and silent mutations across
all the games from all the patients from
the TCGA database pan-cancer so more
than 3,000 patients tested from the
number of silent mutation and we
compared it to the rate of non-imaging
education versus the number of expected
immuno genic medications versus what we
finally observe him when we did the
sequencing and should show that indeed
patients with MS I have increased or are
significantly less immunogenic my
patient than what is expected based on
the rate of silent and non linearity
patients lie
similarly missense mutation was found to
be significantly lacks in MSS patients
and in MSI patient
basically showing with genetic evidence
that immuno editing is occurring in
human humans then there are less than
expected immunogenic mutation
based on genetic sequencing so if this
is the case then we should be able to
detect T sounds that are specific for
friendship integer so what we did was to
take the T cell from the patients who
sequence those patients detect the HLA
appetite restricted to HLA a 202 and
looked at
those having a in that case a tgf-beta
are two function equations and we did
that for some other friendship equations
and what we could see is that for MSI
patients the T sent on these patients
are able to kill on this chromium into
an assay to kill human cells
presenting the frame shift mutation
where has the T cells from an MSS
patient border T cells from a patient
and don't have that mutation are not
able to cure those tumor cells and those
tumor cells having immediate peptides
therefore is possible to detect anti
tumor specific t-cells in those patient
and anti tumor specific friendship
peptides in patients so there is a
mechanistic relationship between those
in Queens friendships and missense
mutations found in MSI patient and the
livelihood of generating an anti tumor
specific cytotoxic T cell response but
when looking at the survival of the
patient what's really matter at the end
of the day for both overall survival on
the left side or disease specific
survival on right side here is the fact
that the patients have generated a
strong adaptive immunity mentioned by
immuno score so here email us call 3 & 4
the top two curves blue and pink are the
patients with a high in your score
whether they are MSS or MSI vice versa
the patient with a low in the low score
of zero one two here yellow and white
curves
shows bad or also viable but Pacific
survival where there they are MSS why
MSI and the multivariate analysis shows
the dependency of Minos of MSI on you
know score milkovic is significant on a
multi by a pole
so the only difference between MSS anime
sign-u is the frequency more frequently
patients women Amazon can generate a
strong adaptive unity and more
frequently they will have a high middle
school but when they don't learn those
patients are not doing well so the fact
that t-cells are essential is likely to
be valid for multiple cancer time
because the immunity doesn't care where
the tumor cells are located and immune
cells are infiltrating all sorts of
tumors and indeed when doing a
meta-analysis of the literature looking
at the prognostic value of subtypes of
t-cells what we found that was published
in that review in nature with your
cancer was that the tumors that are
infiltrated with high densities of
cytotoxic see a thesis or memories
before about our open releases shown
with this blue istagram the good
prognostic value of these cells in most
of the study period the percentage of
article published or the number of
published article 58 out of 60 articles
should be significant good prognostic
value of cytotoxic t-cells
similarly for th one being associated
with um but other subtypes of theater
like th2 th17 regulatory t-cells could
be either good or bad or with no
significant impact depending on the
cancer type and it was studied for more
than 20 different cancer types
so is this quantification of the
greatest community of the t-cells with a
standard as I say like immuno score
clinically relevant we believe so
because when looking at the median
overall survival of the patients or
patients having a high amino score you
know score for with the measurement of
the cytotoxic T cells in the center and
in passive margin those patients will
survive more than 15 years regardless of
any other parameters you know score two
patients will survive five years
Uno's concerns but less than three major
clinical differences but the
reality of clinical practice today is
that it is not taken into account yet so
we went for an easy and simple powerful
immune test in middle school and to test
whether this could be applied in routine
practice the current situation for all
patients with cancer is that only human
self characteristics are measured of
course
the cancer classification made on TNM
staging system plus multiple ways of
classifying tumors and patients based on
human cell characteristics either
anatomic pathology morphology based type
classification either based on the tumor
cell of origin either based on molecular
pathways like chromosomal instability
microsatellite instability based on the
mutation status of the patient or on
tumor gene expression signature but
there is not a single a say that is done
with e to tell us something about the
immune system of a cancer patient we
don't know anything about the immune
status of a cancer patient
there is no measurement of the immunity
to cancer so the idea of immuno score is
to have a first host immune response
evaluation quantifying the density of
cytotoxic T cells in the center and
embed margin of the tumors we propose to
do that and and wrote this review
proposed me include into the
classification of cancer we initiated
with the CDC the Society for
immunotherapy of cancer a consortium
followed by multiple Cancer Society's
animal collected scientist and initiated
this worldwide aminos consortium these
many countries replied and were
interested in participating we need love
harmonization in order and is to decide
what should be the municipal assay and
it's basically the quantification of all
those Brown T cells that you can see
here and to count them one by one by the
software so basically what we did was
that
after immunization of the assay that all
central perform NEMA no score on their
patient the data were q8q seed and sent
to an external statistician outside of
the consortium at the Mayo Clinic all
the clinical data were sent to an us
site that encrypted the data and send it
to the my clean and the statisticians
divided the patients into three chords
so basically what we are doing is a
sterilized quantification of cytotoxic T
cells and T cells inside regular old
slide sections where every single T cell
here is Kunti and for you to know we
average the mean number of T cells on a
given slide an adventurer is 88,000 Tisa
huge bandit and this was validated and
we just published this here the result
of this international study or the
consensus immuno score to classify
correctly cancer patients here is an
example of the densities of immune cells
that were found in more than 3000 cubers
quantified huge densities of immune
cells you can also see the huge
difference more than three logs
difference in the density speed one
between a tumor and another tumor on
another page and all primary endpoints
secondary endpoints survival data were
significant here are the results of the
multivariate analyses showing that the
middle score two or three or five
categories show highly significant
p-values multivariate analysis both for
time to recommend T's which survival
overall survival and this is the
relative contribution to the risk test
showing on the left side the current
situation with all the parameters that
are evaluated today and their relative
contribution to the risk the end stage
and the T stage most important greater
differentiation venue sampling in fact
in variant primal invade now on the
right side you see the same test by
adding immuno score showing the power
and the relative contribution to the
risk of immuno score in comparison to
all the other panel basically the same
a national validation of the consensus
amino score for the classification of
colon cancer gives strong arguments for
Pete reducing all the first time an eye
by immune into the classification of
cancer it CNMI with multiple arguments
and level of evidence to support this
but really what is struggling is this
interesting is really at the metastatic
stage because is there an impact of the
immune response in the defective stage
so what we did was to analyze the EM
stage patients or the tumor of the
primary tumors from patients without
metastases on with metastases and we
published that in time translational
medicine to see what other parameters
that are associated with the
dissemination to distant metastasis we
analyze multiple genetics chromosomal
instability pattern mutation tumor
profiling and immune profiling by
quantifying even my compartment
as the question what in the primary
tumor is associated with early
metastatic dissemination synchronous
metastases or mexicanos metastasis and
basically could show that there are no
or not much going on in terms of genomic
patterns associated with metastasis but
in contrast there's huge differences in
the micro environment that are
associated with or without the
dissemination to distant metastasis what
the most striking findings are the
densities of the cytotoxic cells immune
cells bronze I'm B+ in the center of
humor preventing metastasis
dissemination and the densities of
lymphatic vessels at the invasive margin
of the tumor preventing metastatic this
minute who is there a metastatic at the
metastatic stage an immune estate so we
need to studies we evaluate immunity
within metastasis in this first study we
took only primer at the same type of
primary tumors colon cancer giving the
either metastasis or lung mitosis is an
unlined
more than 400 metastases and perform the
mirror score the consensus immuno score
on the metastases not wanted by mercury
what we found was that high densities of
psychopathic t-cells and Jaime no score
correlated with his blue curves with a
very prolonged overall survival as you
can see five years more than 70% of the
patients have overall apps surviving
five years in contrast luminous called
tumors metastases those patients have
only 20 percent chance of overall
survival at five days we pick the worst
case scenario of patients having brain
metastases in that case the study was
any type of primary tumor the opposite
study giving rise to only one type of
metastasis brain metastasis and we study
the immune micro environment within the
brain Mets and the consensus immuno
score within the brain mass you can see
T cells surrounding the brain metastasis
you can see T cells inside the brain
metastasis and you can see with this
long-term follow up on those patients
having had brain Mets that the patient
with a high middle score in white here
are very prolonged long-term survival
more than five years as you can see here
where has the patient with the luminous
core have much shorter survival showing
me that even in the worst case I know
you have patients having that brain Mets
immuno strong within the metastases
predict survival we followed this by a
study to really analyze the it originate
of the Mets and we analyzed a lung
metastases liver metastases peritoneal
metastases more than 600 metastases from
two quarts of patients quantified
multiple density the remaining cells
which we reported so it's a full
quantification of rejected metastases
much louder than a biopsy of course it's
a full metastasis classification we all
invasive margin of the whole metastases
and the whole center of the metastasis
and basically what we showed and this
has been
accepted for publication in cancer cell
is that there is a little genius
pattern of metastasis the patients with
different metastases are people immune
micro environments that the tumor cells
are different and also the immune cells
are different and that in fact what
really matters for the survival of the
patient is the density and the strength
of the immune response in the least
immune infiltrated metastasis that is
the one that will ultimately kill the
patient we also could analyze the
difference between biopsy analysis in
metastasis versus all slide analysis and
all the purposes analysis and could show
that in fact the accuracy prediction of
different markers for example PDL 1 on
biopsy was really poor in comparison to
the newest core evaluation which was
much better in accuracy prediction in
comparison to the old metastasis then
lastly what drive metastasis what are
the mechanistic escape mechanism and is
it compatible with the current theories
of cancer evolution so what are the
current areas of cancer evolution there
are four main models the linear model
stating that there is an accumulation of
different driver mutations leading to a
cancer development the neutral model
saying that there is no impact of the
type of driver mutations and no
selection the big bang models saying
that there is an initial major Big Bang
of mutations and accumulation of many
mutation before the dissemination and
probably the most accepted branch model
of different drivers giving rise to
different clones with a branch evolution
this common characteristic of all those
theories is that none of them involved a
role of immune system and a possible
immune pressure through
Darwinian selection of a dominant
parameter what we did was to analyze not
only primary tumors
from various special patients having
synchronous metastases and long history
of medical news recommend disease with
multiple medical experiments for more
than 11 years we analyze deeply by doing
sequencing genome sequencing and RNA
looking at the clones and did the tumor
cloned modification the evolution of the
tumor clone the prevalence of those born
within the different metastasis could
follow and place back the loans
basically showing the phylogeny the trio
difference beyond the phylogenetic tree
could should evolve a gram of those
tumor clones so showing that some tumor
clones
persistent in the different metastases
but some are not persisting then what we
found was that in fact the non-recurrent
loans are immuno edited I had the
progressive loan our immune privilege we
could also see that here that the clones
within the metastases have a much higher
immuno editing score lower score means
more immuno editing and that those
clones were eliminating and not
reappearing more than four years after
in contrast to the persistent loans all
of them showing no signs of immuno
additi and at the end of the day when
analyzing all the parameters the number
the type of driver mutations etc what
really was associated with metastasis
records whether for following parameters
the immuno score of the metastasis so
the quantification of the site that CT
cells inside that particle a metastasis
the immuno editing happening in that
metastasis the distance between the T
cells and the ongoing 2418 ki67 positive
tumor cells and the size of the
metastasis and these four parameters are
the ones remaining significant on the
multivariate model explaining the future
records of the patients and of the
metastasis and of
no one who will have so this evolved
Akram showed that there is a multiverse
of metastases evolution in space and
time and very mean selection pressure
there is an evolution of tumor clones
that is linked to the intra metastatic
Indian context and that the non reckon
clothes are immuno edited like these
ones
unlike the progressing clones that are
immune privilege and we propose that
there is a parallel selection model
which is prime this flannel immuno
editing and we propose it parallel
immune selection model to describe tumor
in evolution during the metastatic
process so immuno editing and immuno
score are the predictive factor of
metastasis recurrence as well as the
distance between t-cells and for a tumor
cells and we propose a novel theory of
chance for evolution a parallel immune
selection model which basically takes
you to account is immune pressure in
each of the tumor micro-environment
that is acting on the selection of tumor
cells and we propose that there is a
dynamic interaction of tumor cells with
immune cells and a Darwinian selection
of the unit state and we could show this
with a parallel evolution and multiverse
of metastasis so as a conclusion
nowadays even therapies is becoming the
fourth pillar of cancer treatment since
the approval the recent approval of
implement the anti CT left for t-cell
blocker
acting on t-cells and since the approval
the breakthrough of the year in 2013 we
went to PD one another checkpoint acting
on t-cells now there is an expansion and
an approval month of the month of
different checkpoints Starling missiles
on different cancer types and this
checkpoint targeting details are
realizing the break are breaking
are reactivating the t-cells this t-cell
I just told you about is pre-existing
this pre-existing immunity that we
showed to be so important we are able to
unleash this crazy immunity with agents
that are targeting these t-cells
then we have this little success and
also the clinical success that was
announced yesterday of the Nobel Prize
for Jim Allison and pursue culantro work
on the ctla-4 and anthony pd-1 showing
that it is possible to release the break
from the t-cells and to unleash the
creativity with the manipulation of the
thesis we expect that this will be
happening in multiple different cancer
types and hopefully these are the
survival curves the yellow ones with
immunotherapy long-term survivors in a
subgroup of patient those having the
proper pre-existing immunity
unfortunately still immunotherapy is
efficient for many patients and the era
of combination immunotherapy now aims
are targeting those tumors and to
basically be able to compensate the
immune defects with combination limiter
so I hope that nowadays with immune
standardized assays such as immuno score
and many others we will be able to do an
immune classification of patients
because today is still in any given
clinical trial that is done based on a
specific clinical trial with a specific
type of cancer with a specific mutation
on a particular subgroup of patients the
reality of the immune response is that
it is very etiology and that there are
apple and oranges in terms of immune
response in a given clinical trial and
we better have homogeneous group of
patients which started at immunity
and with that I'd like to thank all the
people in the lab there
talented bastards in the lab all the
clinical centers all our sponsors the
Society for immunity of cancer and to
thank all the centers worldwide moon
validated the Moscow I see and I thank
you for listen thank you dr. Gallin for
that informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left every presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email now let's
get started our first question is think
your findings on clora rectal cancer CRC
could be applicable to different cancer
types yes indeed I think and and the
success of immunotherapy is actually
multiple cancer type so targeting those
t-cells in melanoma learned a damag etc
shows that these t-cells can be
reactivated in multiple cancer types and
also there are many papers showing the
good compost value of those these are to
predict the survival of the patient in
multiple different cancer types
so having an immuno score consensus
assay for all those cancer types I
believe will be very efficient and very
feasible you children and what is the
difference between immunise course an
immune signature are they redundant yeah
so I mentioned that there are functional
immune signatures with different
families of Indian genes that are
associated with the survival of the
patient so stratifying page rank highest
and lowest so it's a different
technology it's a different measurement
in comparison to immuno score neuro
score takes into account the
three first three parameters of Numan
protection so the type of immune cells
they have density is measured by illness
to chemistry's we are counting the cells
and their location also take into
account the spatial distribution of the
cells in contrast the immune signaling
city measurement it's an immunity
profiling it's not taking into account
the location of itself so they are
complementary signatures immuno score
and demons in the third they are partly
redundant because of course when
patients have a high middle score this
is associated with the better at that
community and the better th one was
formed so they have a better immune
signature but each of the assay has a
pros and cons and each of the acid
brings additional information the most
relevant and the easiest to be done in
routine practice would be Evo's Casas
we have time for one more question in
your opinion was the reason why
seriously patients are not responding to
immune checkpoint therapies so that's a
very good point so as I showed you in
middle score is not a static measure in
your score indeed actually the immune
response is changing over time there are
more and more English suppressive
mechanisms so when we immuno score is
decreasing when we adapted immediately
creasing the tumor is progressing the
tumor is invaded which means that at the
latest stage of the disease like
patients with metastasis most of them
now are the lowest or most of them have
a lot of immunosuppressive mechanisms in
place so we are remaining at the latest
metastatic stage stage where the
treatment the immunotherapies are tested
and are given at that stage
unfortunately most of the patients now
have a bad immunity of a low immuno
score a lot of immunosuppressive
mechanical so
think immunotherapy will be even more
efficient at the earlier stage and I
think that in order to be successful in
in in colon cancer we need we need to
tackle and to address multiple
immunosuppressive mechanism not only one
checkpoint will be enough because not
only one checkpoint is overexpressed at
the stage format as that we need you
come on task well I'd like to once again
thank doctor clunkers presentation I'd
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go once let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January of
2019 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
would be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye